cryptocurrencies making a comeback so at
this hour look on your screen these
gains here have helped it retake the 1
trillion global market cap throne
bitcoin was trading earlier today above
22 000 per coin right now we're 21 581
still a gain of about two and a half
percent and we saw that 22 handle for
the first time since june 16th but
ethereum gets most of the credit ether
looking very strong right now a gain of
17
still not at 2000 but it's at 1 000 460
a gain of 213 bucks
it's adding more than 20 billion to the
crypto market in just the past 24 hours
investors piling into the second biggest
digital currency ahead of its upcoming
merge okay this note i didn't say merger
its merge will take it from an energy
intensive proof of work mechanism to an
environmentally friendly proof of stake
mechanism on its blockchain all right if
that's too confusing for you here in a
fox business exclusive we bring in pop
investments anthony pompliano on why
investors see this transition as a
bullish sign to pile in but but anthony
first let's do a dive if we could into
what's floating the entire crypto market
rally right now and when i say entire
market i mean you could look at the
ecosystem stocks marathon digital i mean
this double-digit percentage jump in
this stock at the moment riot blockchain
is looking great coinbase
what's sort of underneath this pumping
it up
yeah i think there's two main things
happening here so first is obviously the
federal reserve's been in control for
the last eight months uh they continue
to tank asset prices and their uh effort
to get inflation down uh and what you
saw was that bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
were the riskiest assets in much of wall
street's uh portfolio and so what
they're gonna go risk off they sell
those assets uh at the same time that
they've been doing that though uh the
average investor globally hundreds of
millions of people uh that are into
bitcoin cryptocurrencies continue to buy
these assets and now what you're seeing
is this psychological pivot uh where
people are realizing this stuff is not
going to zero it is not going away take
bitcoin the largest crypto asset in the
world uh it actually is the signal among
the noise uh when you have undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy uh that
programmatic monetary policy stands out
and i think what you're seeing now is
people say uh as michael saylor said you
know if it's not going to zero it's
going to a million and i think that
you're going to see more and more people
realize this stuff is not going to go
away and that psychological pivot will
take hold well let's get to ether
specifically and props to coindesk
because they really explain it very well
and in essence they're saying for the
first time in six months we're suddenly
seeing it flip from
bearish to bullish here when it comes to
ethers options september 19th though is
this date of completion for its
so-called merge where it's going to flip
from using a very energy intensive
mechanism on its blockchain to more of
an energy sipping mechanism
why is that
so incredibly bullish for ether at the
moment
if i were to triangulate i would think
that maybe people look at this and say
oh regulators are worried
about how energy intensive bitcoin
mining is so maybe this makes ether more
attractive
yeah let's first take on the energy
conversation if the regulators are
worried about energy consumption they
probably should go look at other things
uh bitcoin as an industry 60
of the energy consumption comes from
renewable energy the american economy is
20 or less so if anything the state of
energy consumption by bitcoin should be
put up on a pillar and we should say to
every single other industry you should
be more like bitcoin they have 60
energy consumption why are you not able
to do the same thing the second thing
that i would point out is that energy
consumption is not bad as we are
watching around the world this pursuit
of the nonsense esg narrative has left
countries like germany at the uh kind of
sword of russia uh and what we need is
we actually need energy consumption
energy consumption makes the value okay
but can i just say i i gotta disagree
with you if you're in texas right now
energy consumption is a massive problem
and they just had regulators there
asking they didn't require it but they
asked bitcoin miners to cease for a
couple of hours on a couple of days
because we are seeing triple digit
record temperatures in the lone star
state and because these bitcoin miners
thankfully did
cease and desist for the moment it
turned out that that added a thousand
megawatts of energy
back into the texas power grid
yeah this is a great point liz so uh
it's not so much that they demanded it
the bitcoin miners this is their entire
pitch they're gonna go around the united
states of america and bitcoin mining is
going to become a core component of grid
stabilization and what we saw in texas
was uh there's a surplus of energy at
times and so the bitcoin miners soak
that up they're able to turn energy into
monetary value and it's incredibly
profitable for them to do that but when
the grid needs that power when the grid
is uh being destabilized or needs help
those bitcoin miners turn around and
they send that energy back and so it's
not a question of oh the bitcoin miner
is good or bad actually in fact what the
state of texas has realized is that
bitcoin miners are a crucial component
to stabilize energy grids and there
doesn't need to be all these role uh
blackouts and things like that and so
what i think you're going to see is that
texas is becoming an example and around
this country we are going to have
bitcoin miners they're going to beg them
to come to their state to help stabilize
those energy
okay i'll i'll wait to see that because
right now texas is down for the count as
they they're looking at rolling
blackouts